[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter LaBelle
speaking to West Point graduates Trump
said were ending the era of endless wars
four years ago on the campaign trail he
said essentially the same thing why is
it so difficult for this president to
make good on this promise why make the
promise again if it can't be kept
[Music]
- crosstalk endless war I'm joined by my
guest James Jefferson Washington he's a
retired US diplomat and former foreign
policy adviser to the US Senate
Republican leadership and in New York we
have growing Licklider he is a professor
emeritus of political science at Rutgers
University as well as an adjunct senior
research analyst at the Institute of war
and peace studies at Columbia University
all right gentlemen cross thought girls
in effect that means you can jump in
anytime you want and I always appreciate
it okay James let me go to you first on
this you you were on crosstalk during
the campaign essentially during the
election and after the election and what
what caught our eye mostly about Trump's
candidacy was his willingness to rethink
some of the pillars of American foreign
policy and I was excited about that I
have to say that I know you were too and
I think there was a national interest
article that had his name on it but I
think there were a lot of people that
had their finger prints on that article
when we talked about it too is a little
odd but he is moving in some right
directions here you know and now we have
the president week ago speaking to
graduate and records at West Point and
he's saying something that he said
during the campaign as far as I'm
concerned that's an unkept promise and I
I'm not disappointed he once they keep
the put that promise out there again
because we already heard that promise
James well your reaction oh you're right
it isn't unkept promise I mean to his
credit at least he has not started any
new Wars yet and that's despite severe
pressure I think for many quarters
especially with respect to Iran but that
said you're right you know he is not he
has not gotten this out he says he wants
to get out of Germany now he wants to
get out of Syria he wants to get out of
Afghanistan and he never managed this
quite to do and we can speculate what
the reasons are maybe it's in terms of
his own untidy way of approaching things
personally maybe it's because there's
terrible appointees which itself is a is
a question why does he appoint these
people or maybe it's the strength of the
institutional structures of government
and make it virtually impossible for
anybody to actually buck the system and
to do something other than
and what the system wants to do I really
don't know at the end of the day it
doesn't really matter but I think coming
back to the well on the promise shows
that he understands this is what the
American people want they don't want
these wars anymore maybe even do Biden
will pay lip service to it to at some
point but uh you know we are where we
are Peter mu affecting the same thing
here I mean it's it's obvious there's
something that he wants to do and I and
it's obvious that the public opinion
polls have made it very clear that they
want these endless wars to end it so
it's much easier to say it than actually
do it I suppose go ahead professor what
wars are we talking about well I mean
getting out of Afghanistan getting out
of Iraq getting out of Syria why are we
it's alleged attempted coup against
Venezuela and they knew we have on this
more pressure extreme pressure on Iran I
mean this is just a continuation of past
administrations yes
but in fact the level of violence here
number of Americans really involved in
killing folks which is how I understand
war on is in fact really small and is
not increased and if anything is
probably decreased over time again I
think it depends on what you see these
into these actions is involved most of
them stem I think from 9/11 and from the
confirm concern for Islamic terrorism at
this point at least that threat seems to
have decreased substantially or if not
disappeared but we had President Trump
saying that he wanted to leave Syria
those of us that were hoping for that
were actually quite overjoyed and then
very suddenly that policy devolved back
to where it was I mean protecting
serious oil
I mean well how in the world is that in
America's national interest and I could
point out to our viewers here I mean
it's against even the sanctions that the
United States has put against Syria and
so is the United States going to export
that oil because that would be breaking
American sanctions I mean does anybody
think these things through please
continue well look the one thing we know
about our president is he does not
thinks things think things through he
acts on impulse whatever strikes his
fancy the broader question which we're
addressing here I think is what is the
American government doing as a as a
whole and maybe our perceptions are
different my sense is that the level of
violence is is low I don't see any
obvious evidence that it's going to
increase now again it depends a little
bit we haven't talked about China for
example the South China Sea and that
whole set of issues um but at that point
you're talking about a very different
kind of national security threat then
Islamic terrorism and you can reasonably
argue that you might want to use force
in one area but just sort of saying
endless war seems to me doesn't get us
very far well I'm just I'm just floating
the president of the United States okay
those aren't my words they it's his
words okay James you already mentioned
it and we heard it during the the circus
called the impeachment process what was
it the interagency consensus that's what
you're getting to so I mean it was it
was shown to be quite blatant that the
president of the United States doesn't
necessarily have to be involved with the
interagency consensus okay because
obviously these people within his own
administration we're working at
cross-purposes here I mean they weren't
elected Trump was go ahead James
exactly right and and this is where I
maybe disagree with Roy a bit is that
look when we talk about endless wars
we're not just talking about what they
call kinetic action the level of
violence we're talking about the entire
posture of America's attempt to maintain
a global hegemony its footprints and all
sorts of places on the planet where our
national security interests are rather
slim to none nonetheless we intend we
expect to remain it seems seemingly
forever and then we do things like you
mentioned Peter sanctions on Syria which
don't even any pretend anymore that
they're directed against the regime
but really to make people's lives as
miserable as possible I also don't buy
the notion that this is all because of
9/11 and Islamic terrorism after all
we've been supporting Islamic terrorists
in Syria as we did in other countries
like Libya everybody forgets about all
that matter in the Balkans that we've
got this the symbiosis with Islamic
terrorists so we can hold it as a
boogeyman when we want to but as a
practical matter we can use as our
proxies in these various wars in fact I
I think there's good reason to believe
we're even helping to stoke the fires
and shinjang with the Islamic movement
there so III think this idea of endless
wars can't just be limited to how much
shooting is going on but rather the
entire I hate to say it aggressive
posture of the United States on a global
scale over the last certainly since the
first Cold War with the so Union ended
you know what is the reasoning for I
mean I think by any estimation the
Middle East is basically a strategic
backwater but why is the United States
continued to invest so money so much
money resources even manpower and the
most and one of the most important
allies is Saudi Arabia I mean it's
really quite obvious that we're not
really aligned at almost any other way
it just seems to me it's like inertia
it's just inertia it's because what's
what we do I think that's that's and
that's a foreign policy that is fatigue
then it has no introspection go ahead
look Middle East was seen as important
for a very long time because of and
while the United States is in a position
to break much of that oil is in fact a
global issues not a not a national one
at this stage of the game the
interesting issue was Iran and what the
Iranian government is interested in
doing now this has some peculiar
implications as you touched on I mean
you know what's the connection between
that and 9/11 well you know Greece
minimum there are different kinds of
Islamic folks involved and it is ironic
that of most of the attackers in 9/11
came from Saudi Arabia is here and a
threat to the United States yes I think
in the sense that if in fact it decides
to close off the Persian Gulf and cut
and alter oil prices in some substantial
way I think it has direct impact on you
or Western Europe and I think Western
Europe is absolutely central to the
United States Iran actually reacting to
America American foreign policy I mean
they're not the proactive player here
they're reacting to sanctions that are
really quite horrific and anyone says
it's directed against the regime is
either doesn't know what they're talking
about or they're lying I mean it's
obvious they want to punish the people
of Iran I mean my point is is that Iran
has its own foreign policy agenda that's
fine but wouldn't it be more reason to
let the Middle East work itself out I
mean because you have this you have this
situation where the United States
assault is an arbiter and it actually
creates dependency on many regimes in
the Middle East for not being proactive
in their form but let the Americans take
care but let them pay for it I think
that there's a lack of imagination here
I'm sorry it was a long question go
ahead yeah that's certainly one strategy
basically you say okay let those folks
take care of their problems and if all
of this only involve the Middle East
that makes perfect sense
it doesn't look James jumpy and how do
you react to that again I fundamentally
disagree here first off there there is a
American policy in the Middle East is
kind of two-headed it's obviously oil
energy something that really shouldn't
concern us much anymore and then of
course the other thing is Israel which
is the other I would say non-economic a
pillar of American policy in the region
and that has all sorts of roots to it
that we can discuss I remember her katie
mcfarland formerly of the NSC was
interviewed at CPAC a few months ago and
she pointed out that because of our
energy independence
at least at that time that we no longer
had any interest in the tribal quarrels
of the Middle East great and then she
said and that's why we can now go and
Hammer Iran and why do we kill general
Soleimani because we can't now the nice
is just absolutely stunning that we
don't care about the tribal quarrels so
let's dig down and really hammer one of
the parties in a tribal quarrel now of
course Iran is not a threat to the
United States it possibly is a threat to
Israel Israel sitting on a pile of
nuclear weapons I kind of think they can
probably handle that themselves but any
case all these people in Middle East
have one thing in common they ain't us
and our direct national interests are
really not at stake there with regard to
Europe and its dependence on on Middle
Eastern oil remember we're the ones who
are insisting on trying to cut off Nord
Stream 2 in other ways that Europe can
secure its own in and energy security
through a natural relationship economic
relationship with Russia all of this
comes down to as kind of a self licking
ice cream cone we have to maintain
global dominance because otherwise we
couldn't maintain global dominance and I
think it's become a self-perpetuating
its justification well you know all
these mansions out here in the
Washington suburbs don't pay for
themselves there are a lot of people
whose rice bowls get filled by endless
Empire and look we've got a revolution
going on here at home everyone is
registered as a foreign agent after a
short break we'll continue our
discussion on ending endless wars say
without
[Music]
welcome back to cross stop where all
things are considered I'm here Lavelle
to remind you we're talking about ending
endless wars
[Music]
okay Ryan let me go back to you here I
want to kind of extend them with
something that James said here and this
is this interagency consensus here I
mean is that real in your mind because
then it really kind of says that it
doesn't really matter who the president
is because the bureaucracy is already to
determine the priorities of American
foreign policy and well the president
can say something who doesn't
necessarily mean it's going to happen as
a matter of fact it's quite obvious I
mean in a lot of trumps problems with
foreign policy or self-inflicted why in
god's name did he appoint bolton i mean
it was just stunning okay and in which
you know saying with this the the the
phrase ending end was force I don't mean
like ending conflicts we should throw in
there to going like North Korea you know
I have a lot of issues with President
Trump on all kinds of things but I
thought it took a lot of courage to go
and meet the North Korean leader I
thought it was something that was never
done before it was a chance and because
of the the deadlock that we've had for
so long here and it seemed obvious to me
that his administration just torpedoed
that and make actually made him look
like foolish and so you know is what is
it that can change foreign policy is it
really that strong of a consensus if it
is that it has nothing to do with what
the president ran on and won on go ahead
look one of the key issues here is
personnel
and it is quite striking that while
Trump talks about ending in this Wars he
has a real passion for people who want
to continue them yeah I mean he makes
very hawkish people and puts them in
very strong position it is the case he
doesn't want to appear soft probably I
mean you look you need a psychiatrist
for this one but you know your
application is that the bureaucracy is
doing its own thing what I'm arguing is
when you pick hawkish people to run the
bureaucracies the brach who sees will do
that gaps if you appointed different
people with different kinds of concerns
and interests you do different behavior
yes I think you would now their son
obviously a lot of inertia here so
bureaucracies are like you know
locomotives they move slowly in the same
direction the best prediction for what a
bureaucracy will do today is what it did
yesterday but they can in fact they
change but they have to be change from
the top you can't change this um I sort
of sniping at sniping at the edges which
is essentially what what Trump's
comments imply right you know I'll say
this and things will happen well but you
got to put people in there who actually
believe that and you guys have done that
so I think it's tight it's a little
unfair to say well maybe it isn't I
think it's unfair to simply say that
bureaucracy is gonna do this regardless
James then Trump is just hapless okay I
mean I mean he says something so he
knows that no one's gonna react to it I
mean there has to be an explanation for
this here I mean the example of Syria is
the perfect one he's getting out of
Syria okay and then all of a sudden you
know if all the the brakes lock up and
everyone you know hair on fire I mean I
was just astounded by that reaction I
was actually resounded by the reaction
to Trump's address to the graduates at
West Point I mean everyone saw airs on
fire
I mean they're just so determined the
weight should be queit this guy out so
they can continue doing what they're
doing which I don't see and this is my
personal opinion that doesn't advance a
national interest whatsoever okay at all
and it just says a huge drain on the
Treasury when we so when we have so many
domestic problems at home go ahead Jess
I wish he had picked better people and
you know if wishes were horses then
beggars would ride but none of that
happened and it's not going to happen I
don't think would happen in a second
term he managed to win remember how much
even his adversaries praised him on the
two occasions when he hit Syria with
prison oh that was that was his being
that was being presidential when he did
that but what anybody wants to get out
of Syria which by the way is a
deployment it's illegal any way you look
at it either under international law or
American law oh as you say here it goes
on fire I don't think it's an either/or
to say bad pointees or the bureaucracy
for whatever reason he has and I'm not
going to speculate he has picked bad in
bad appointees who are essentially in
sync with the global hegemonist program
be inertia as Lloyd points out of the
bureaucracy I don't think I think the
problem is that there isn't anybody
riding herd on them they want to change
direction and I think that we saw what
would happen in the case of general
Flynn if anybody who was even suspected
of wanting to change the direction he'd
be putting his head through a noose
anyway so he he picks people that
essentially are part of the problem and
here we are so he is effectively not
commander in chief he's more of a
tweeter in shape well you know Jameson
then the implication or at least one of
the implications of this is that foreign
policy is completely divorced to the
democratic process I mean even no matter
what people vote for they need abrecan
bureaucracy say well we know better okay
and I think that that is very tragic
there's there's strong evidence research
done on the 2016 election where the
congressional districts that were key
for Trump's victory were congressional
districts that had veterans active
service
retirees I mean people that had served
in the military and his words of
ending these conflicts resonated with
them and now we don't know for sure but
that might have you know made the
difference for him the last time around
and I think it's really half the sad
that he has to go out and have to say
the same thing again I don't know he's
being advised to do that I don't know I
mean speeches to West Point are made up
on a back of an envelope I imagine here
Roy is there a is there such a thing as
a trump foreign policy in your mind
no okay I mean there are these sort of
hints and allegations but in terms of
actually doing something and not much is
there I do think he has a weakness or he
he likes I think to be surrounded he
likes force he likes the idea of force
and I think he likes being surrounded by
people who you think are things are
really tough and strong um
why that is yeah that's your
psychiatrist problem let me flip it the
other way let's assume Biden wins as the
economists say a Sulha Biden victory and
then the question is do we in fact get
any and let's secondly assume that Biden
really doesn't want to cut down on all
the stuff do we then assume that
bureaucracy will do the same thing and
he will be unable to do this I mean I
think it's unfair to say that
bureaucracy has successfully resisted
all these different disparate efforts by
by drunk to change the policy because
Trump hasn't made a serious effort to
change the policy he's just a cleated
about it or chelyn because for me it's
very important because we've never had a
candidate that actually in at least in
my estimation tried to get a fresh look
on foreign policy and say maybe we can
do it a different way like I mean the
literati you know in all the cable
station you know doubting NATO I mean
anyone
that knows anything about NATO there's
been there's a huge literature on is
NATO necessary in 2020 but they have
reacted if it was some you know
sacrilegious thing I mean serious people
have said you know they've discussed it
okay I mean it's not as if it was
Trump's original idea but the idea
itself is worth talking about
okay moving troops from Germany to
Poland I mean that doesn't change
anything James jump in well you know
it's lurking behind all the talk about
getting out of endless wars was also
improving ties with Russia which he also
promised in 2016 and of course in
response we got this hysterical brusha
brusha brusha thing over the past few
years you know I hate to think of the
prospect of Joe Biden winning because I
think basically that's going to see the
consolidation of the wolf dictatorship
here at home and I'm terribly afraid of
that I do wonder however if a president
and Biden would be capable of actually
reaching out to Moscow in a way that
Trump is prevented from doing in a way
that it took a Nixon to go to Beijing in
the 1970s so that a Democrat could not
have done that but a Republican could
and I wonder if somebody from the party
off of Russia Gaiden Russia's Syria
actually has more freedom in this area
assuming he would want to do that which
I don't know sir
games I got some bad news for you okay
is that I think at this point if a hand
has reached out it's not going to be
taken because there's so much distrust
right now I mean all of these sanction
is baseless based on nothing
it's really quite insulting and in the
whole issue with you mentioned it very
well on budget the North stream I mean
you know the United States is could
determine the energy policy of every
single country on the planet
I mean countries like Russia and China
say why we're not be good including the
rare okay and so I don't I think there's
that inertia that we've been talking
about and that isn't going to change so
and wrong that we're rapidly running out
of time here
well how do you explain this mantra to
get rid of all arms control agreements
is that reasonable in your mind no it's
crazy it's crazy absolutely no you know
I think all I think all those agreements
that he overlooked he starts up by
scrapping the agreement with Iran which
I think was the mislead me I mean that's
just bizarre
um and then he winds up having to say
okay well maybe we're gonna do it again
hello Trust trust Tetris no but but look
if you're appealing to his what he sees
as his base and anything that looks
strong in international affairs is
wonderful and anything that looks weak
has to be thrown out and that's what he
did and I my sense is that it didn't
play well to the base reporters what do
you think don't you think also
considering Trump space being a
peacemaker that also shows strength I
mean you know everybody remembers Nixon
for Watergate in popular culture but
James already pointed out Richard Nixon
and Henry Kissinger pulled off a
Bismarck Ian's gambit in opening up to
China it was a brilliant absolutely
brilliant and I think Trump considering
he had no baggage he could have said
look let's go back to the do we will
keep this Agreement but let's go figure
out and what they should have done and
saying are other issues keep the
agreement and then say we've got this
and now we can talk about things that we
really need to talk about I think that
could have gotten some traction there
and then unfortunately I leave the
torpedo okay Roy I'll give you the last
25 seconds go ahead
sorry it's TV what no I mean I think the
the deliberate undermining of a whole
set of agreements that have been
carefully reached to try to make
large-scale violence less likely is was
grossly irresponsible and it's gonna and
it is set up at and it is concet a sense
abroad that the United States cannot be
trusted because any new president will
change the whole thing and that's a
long-term cost we're going to have to
gentlemen that's all the time we have
want to thank my guests in Washington
and in New York and I want to thank our
viewers for watching us here are two you
see you next time remember
crosstalk words
[Music]